okay uh so we did the the um ASI
saaki and then we did the Tachi to give
us the edmi
angle and and I talked about how there
is a the ability to internalize the Yang
aspect necessary for myi okay so we're
going to take that part off and let's
just look at
uh the kazushi of the x pattern it is
quite quite different from everything
I've seen out there okay um and you have
to be careful if you're trying to do my
way because the other way is an anti-
way it's not a variant it's not an
alternative it's it does not function
okay so a couple things um um we have to
continue working with that Yin Yong grid
okay so as we brought from the atmi on
the wui we brought the wrist to that
where that hand can now take over this
hand will move to the Y Line so that the
elbow can now go to the wui line you
don't want to keep the wrist wrist there
on the center line and the elbow on the
Yang line that does not work because
what we're doing is going from body
control to an arm isolation that begins
at the wrist and then gets coupled with
the elbow that is the Tactical
sequence um because that's always the
Tactical sequence for arm isolations
attack the body the arm will become
isolatable work from the wrist to
control the elbow and the wrist that's
that's how you do it whether it's a
knife disarm or an arresting method or a
Nea technique that's how you do it
okay um
so
when we move him you see I go to the to
the wrist so you attack the body in the
kazushi that exposes the arm it's
isolated now from his Center Line that's
what you're doing from his Mass you go
to the wrist then you get the the elbow
and now you have Arm Control once you
have wrist and elbow okay but the next
thing is all pins always have to go
underneath you they don't go go out out
away from you they have to go underneath
you and that means they have to go in
towards you so down and in is the PIN
not up and out there's no pin up and out
throws are up and out pins are in and
down um
so if I take his energy like on a lot of
uh ferite iido they move him away like
that do you see and this is not control
I don't have control over this limb he
can get
up
um so let's look at why like anyone who
fights or tries to arrest people knows
that if you throw if you if you push
energy away from you you're never
getting it back the opponent will extend
it out where you will not have control
because it's away from your Center Line
you're not as strong there your gravity
your your mass is not as heavy there and
so you never throw the opponent the
arreste the suspect outward with the
expectation that you're going to control
them okay but I think what a lot of iido
people
think is they see that he's on this
one-legged
base and then they push him off balance
so he falls like that okay
um and they think that's an advantage it
it might be maybe if I want to follow
him with a kick but not if I want to
control the arm okay so the first thing
to do is these Discovery learning
exercises
um so in most uh Dojo that I've seen
they're never in the center so they
never get here and this person is always
here when they shove them down this way
see and
um again it looks like my foot is here
and then he pushes my Bas of support he
pushes my line of gravity out you end up
like
that but because I'm here and you have
to understand let me up for a second
stay there though
is the basis
support is the area of contact with the
Earth and then shaded in and I'm not off
balance until my line of Gravity Falls
outside of that Bas of
support So if you look when I'm here and
now I have that hand then I have a
larger Bas of support from this triangle
to these three bases okay and
um there's nothing he can do to stop me
putting that hand
anywhere so now I'm
pretty big of a base and he has to get
my line of gravity from here all the way
past that base so he's going to try
that and that's kind of what you feel in
real life and and of course because my
picture elbow control is Not underneath
his Center but out here I he can't
control that and I can use that base to
Counterattack so your first discovery
learning note that nogget can never
control where you put this hand two go
ahead and have someone try to shove you
over and then three with as long as this
elbow Is Not underneath the center line
just pull your arm
back and attack the leg those are the
first three Discovery learnings okay
let's try
it okay so this these three Discovery
learnings are all necessary to
understand
because modern iido seeks to control the
body through the arm as opposed to
control the body then the arm becomes
isolatable that's that's the way the
rest of the martial arts Community does
it except for iido they're going to get
your arm and they're going to you're
going to control people from that it
doesn't work like that okay um here's
another
one which works off that same state
okay um let's say I'm not strong enough
because this is a matter of Leverage
it's just such Superior Leverage
uh that it that you can just hold your
base here but if I wasn't strong enough
and he's trying to shove me down into
here the next to Discovery learning is
you can always move your
Bas okay and he can enter and
enter however many
times it's not ever going to
change or
you can extend his energy so as he's
pushing out I extend his
energy and he can't control it so those
two Discovery learning exercises now try
those now again as I talked to Juan a
lot of my stuff comes out of my fight
experience like actually trying to do
this on people who don't want this done
to them actually trying to arrest
somebody who does not want to be
arrested you you just learn really
quickly I I can't control I can't pin
someone I can't stabilize someone I
can't reduce the mobility of someone by
sending them away from me that's for
throwing okay uh you also learn that
arms don't make themselves available you
can't find the body from the arm you
first take the body then you find the
arm that's the order okay um but even if
you didn't do these exercises and Ivan
and you were in the bonai
lineage there is a style to the ukemi
that
exposes exactly what we just
demonstrated here as counters to that
technique okay
so
um he's going to be here and when he
shoves me over the good hook is will
always put that foot over there because
of the energy that's actually wants them
to extend it like that and so it's very
stylistic that all the good
ukas you go go like you mean it all
right go you'll see them do that kind of
stuff you see and that whole energy
there is to stop me from keep
rolling
okay with which is why your crappy
ukes crappy ukes in the
bonai go like this do you see and then
we beat the out of them for landing
supine when they weren't supposed to or
we train them hey put your foot back
here get your hip up and we say like
stay alive but you're you're not staying
alive you're actually dead okay all
right so we'll play with
that all right so if you look at all of
this stuff here it all and this is the
part that's the most
problematic is that the elbow control is
not under my Center you see the elbow
control is not under my center it's off
to the right either at the Young line or
outside of the Y Line as it is in this
case do you see and then the next
assumption is
that this
is um a
shikaku so cooperate please that you can
now and he will fall into that but he
goes
back and again you have to
think in terms of the kinesiological
elements Bas to support line of gravity
so his his line of gravity is full on in
his Bas of support which is his whole
body it's not over here outside of his
Bas of support so when I try to pull
this there's no effing way that I can
get
this over there there's absolutely no
way okay uh so we'll do that next
Discovery learning exercise so you went
outside you sent the energy outside your
y line now you're going to try to bring
it back back and you're going to feel it
doesn't ever come back okay all right
try it
out okay so again normally this all
works but it works because the UK is
making it work the the UK is putting
their foot back right and then the UK is
not resisting and laying down for you on
that second part um but you could see
architecturally that you're already
you're already violating sound body
mechanics your control point should be
underneath your Center sound energetic
uh aspects you should be on the rouie
line um and then sound tactics pins are
under and in not up and out those are
throwing architectures
okay um and this is going to be a pin so
there's some other things too there is
the overall energetics and the
alchemical principles to pay attention
to and in particularly as as they uh
deal with non-c contestation because
those other things could actually work
if you had enough Yong to make relevant
Yin out of their resistant potential
okay um but that won't make them right
just because you were strong enough to
overcome that young output that's still
going to be wrong okay so we have to
look at what we're doing we know we
attack the body and as the body is
experiencing kazushi we know that it's
going to go around and inside me because
that's the way the body wants to fall
once we create this pattern the leg
wants to swing around the head wants to
go
in uh we also
know that there's going to be resistance
on this elbow because he doesn't want to
go down so I can't shove him down I have
to bring this around me that's what I do
because I have to do a 90° fluctuation
to the contest so that I don't
participate in it okay um so as we're
going
along I picked this up at the wui line
this hand as I start to go
through this hand is going to attack uh
the height
Dimension
as it fuels this hand on the width
dimension so what I mean by that is this
hand keeps turning this to keep that
shoulder
down as it brings it over to the Y Line
here this
way as it goes this way that creates the
adhesion that I need on the elbow to now
assist with that
turning of his elbow this way take keep
that shoulder going down so that I aim
his falling
body and it looks like this and it ends
under my
Center so uh rewind
slightly because this is turning his
shoulder down and this is turning his
shoulder down he's not going up like the
other technique see I'm not sh in him
this way where I end up in that thing or
the crappy UK who goes to Pine in bonai
do you
see
turn as it moves to here turn as it goes
from Yong to wui and
ends under my Center
turn as it goes from muuji to Yang as it
goes from Yong to wuji
turn it ends under my Center on the wui
here so sometimes we show the break here
to show that you have
control okay so we'll do that mode Let's
try
[Music]
sh
so if you plot his head to plot his head
in a vertical plane on the other
technique his head is going to go that
way same beginning orientation his head
will go around me which is required for
the rotating spiraling cross his head
goes around it's going to go this
way almost looking back the other way
okay and that's how you can tell am I
doing it right and and the reason this
head goes
around is because as I transfer from
body control there to wrist control to
Elbow control I'm not pushing him away
like that that makes his head go that
way I'm bringing him in and down in and
down his head comes with its arm which
is telling you now I am controlling his
body from the arm
okay
um might as well do the second part so
the second part is he's laying
down and we'll have the other
technique and this is the one we already
know this is not
possible and this should not have been
there this should been
here and his head should be there
okay even if he's a little
up sometimes I don't wait for the whole
pin you don't don't
pull you don't pull that way you're
going to make this is the contesting
angle so shoving it is
contesting you are going to go up
it he doesn't want to go that way you go
up
it and when you go up
it you will not you'll make this
shoulder go down down not by pulling it
and he falls but by attacking the
joint this way like
that with your
body now the shoulders
pin
so now youve made your figure eight we
go on he goes around me ohom now I go
around him
and so there should
be three pins in the
technique the first
one is this brake here crack right there
the second one is when I come around
it's right here on the elbow and the
third one is a shoulder dislocation when
you come through okay so you could do
that you got him here get the tap here
on the elbow
then the break here on the elbow and
then the
shoulder dislocation there that's
telling you you have the right vectors
through the arm but the pattern
is around
me around him that's what you're doing
boom around
me around him
okay we'll try it go right so uh the the
first part is he's he's doing spinal
displacement
okay and you're yielding right and
projecting right there there's your
projection it's not it's not me going
into his shoulder and trying to get his
arm he's
projecting that's
it
technique e
then as you
watch this
part pay attention because it doesn't
really take
if I crank here it's going to take some
strength but as I start turning over
here it doesn't take strength and the
same thing here if I shove down here
it's going to take some strength but I
don't need strength at this point don't
need strength okay because I'm not ever
contesting he was falling from the
beginning and I just aim him be the arm
isolation that opened up from the attack
on the center the kazushi that is what
you're trying to do I'm not saying do it
that way you should learn the
technique but it should feel that way
boom there's no real pressure to him it
feels tight as but to me it doesn't
okay all right
try e
we'll do that last part okay so
down and again this energy is going down
this way okay from the claw turning that
does that so go back it's I'm not going
here because this arm keeps turning you
do you feel that yes that's right
so put Chris come put your hand right
here just put your hand right there so
we have a visual reference don't push
down on it okay I'm not trying to go
here I'm turning this don't let it move
dude that wouldn't make sense as his
shoulder rolls your hand would move you
get it do you understand what I want cuz
we can't see it in thee so your hand is
a visual reference so I'm not you don't
have to do anything I'm not trying to
shove this down here I'm turning this
this way that's what I'm doing okay then
you can let go now when I move him
around I'm not moving his arm
forward I am taking this arm
see how there's a little little inch
there you hear it okay when I
go
together and then out I can push this
this way uh Virginia come here
please go go underneath my
legs I'll tell you what to do and you'll
hold his elbow with two hands
and it's like she's pulling his elbow
tap when you don't like it okay that's
what's happening with this hand this
this hand is doing that action you can
let go it's not that
I'm going this way doing
that I'm going in boom and that makes
that arm go even lower when I do now
it's now I have the pin Okay so likewise
Maya when you're here and you get here
now you push him away from you we don't
push pinning away from us it's pushing
away from us you see it doesn't it comes
back in which is why you can get that
that break right there it's coming back
in towards me back in and under okay you
just have to release it to continue to
the last one okay all right try it again
so you when when you take the a
beginner's KY a beginner's uh balance
for real when you when you do this they
want to go flying like that that's why
it's very important that you follow the
hand
workk then then they can't they can't go
flying he can only go flying if I make
this arm go that way or I let that arm
go that way if if he's trying to roll
out you see he's trying to roll out as
I'm doing you can't even tell that he
was even trying it the only thing that I
could tell is he smashed his nose on the
map which is what I always say you're
going to go it's how you're going to
land that you get to choose by by trying
to get out of the technique you will you
will pay the price of the technique okay
so
sometimes on new
people not committed people which is the
is saying I will I will not want to kill
them okay so I can feel that he's trying
to roll out and I kind of Let It Go and
you'll kind of go into that thing you
see what I do is I stop the technique
and now I'm going to start it
again remember that it's from here that
I do the spiral so I know I can't pull
this way I just do the
spiral and and it's a kind of punishment
because it still hurts but I do it just
enough to let them know and to let me
know that I'm still controlling the
center from the arm at that point okay
and you still have to follow the the
same rules so he's PR he suine okay and
I know this is too far out it has to get
over here I know I can't pull it I know
I have to fluctuate so I start turning
it this way and now I'm back in the
technique and now I can continue the
technique okay if
uh and tap when you don't want you you
can of course pin from here you see it's
a pin so I'm pinning it just enough
where I let him roll but it's not
comfortable for that UK okay and now you
start the trainability of the UK okay
cuz the fear that wanted them to escape
Cape is now used to correct them cuz
they won't like that either but you
didn't kill them or hurt them okay and
you got to practice the same technique
from just a slight pause and a new
starting point
okay e